Il y a tellement de musique quand il devient difficile de respirer.
Cela fait très mal et vous essouffle.
Nous sommes tellement pollués que
Ça devient tellement grave que tu ne peux pas dire non.
Nous sommes également impuissants et ne pouvons pas le dire et nous sommes comme ça seulement.
On dit que le gouvernement a très peu fait pour réduire la pollution.
[musique]
faire
Les niveaux de pollution augmentent depuis 10 à 12 jours
Je me sens vraiment en pleine croissance à Delhi aujourd'hui
Ce qui s’est passé se passe à l’intérieur de la glace et pendant longtemps il y a eu beaucoup de suffisance.
Cela signifie plus si vous avez regardé autour de vous.
Il y a beaucoup de smog donc je suis reconnaissant que ce soit suffisant
La situation est normale à Delhi mais je pense
Je ne suis pas bon en
[musique]
L
Et voyant ça maintenant à Delhi
Implémenter la deuxième phase de Grab
donné
Est
[musique]